- Thank you all so much for
joining this installment
of the Yale Program for
the Study of Antisemitism's
Benjamin and Barbara
Zucker lecture series.
I'm Josh Kalla,
and I'm an Assistant
Professor of Political Science
and Statistics and Data
Science at Yale University,
and I'm very excited to
be inviting Laura Royden
to give us a talk today
on antisemitic attitudes
among young Americans.
Laura is a fifth-year PhD student
in the Government Department
at Harvard University.
She is currently focused on antisemitism
and Jewish politics,
but also interested in
election and judicial politics.
Prior to starting her PhD at Harvard,
Laura worked at the
Brennan Center for Justice
in the Harvard Kennedy School.
She completed her
undergraduate studies at MIT
in Urban Studies and Planning in 2014.
And we're very excited to
have you at this joint program
of the Yale Program for
the Study of Antisemitism,
and the American and
Comparative Political Behavior
workshop.
Throughout the talk, if
you have any questions,
please put those in the Q and A.
And if there are clarifying
questions during the talk,
I will moderate those and
potentially interrupt Laura
with those clarifying questions.
And then if you have
substantive questions,
please try and save those for the end
and put those in the Q and A in Zoom.
Chat is disabled and we're
not going to call on people,
so please just put everything
in that Q and A function.
And with that, I will
hand it over to Laura.
Thank you Laura.
- Thanks Josh for that introduction.
Thanks to Yale for having me,
and thanks to everyone for coming today.
I'm really excited to be here
to talk about this project,
which has been a joint effort
with Eitan Hersh at Tufts.
Broadly speaking,
this project is a series of
survey questions and experiments
that we designed to examine
antisemitic attitudes
among American adults.
I think we originally
envisioned this project
being one paper, but it
ended up turning into three,
because we realized we
really wanted enough space
to be able to discuss
the topic and our results
with the level of nuance
that I think we can all agree it deserves.
Three papers is obviously way too much
to present fully in the next 45 minutes.
So I'm gonna present
some of the core findings
from one of the papers, which
was recently published in PRQ,
for the political scientists.
And this one focuses on
ideological and age dimensions
of antisemitic attitudes in the US.
So I'm gonna talk through our theory,
our hypotheses, and our findings.
And end briefly by highlighting our work
in the other two papers.
Of course, I'm happy to
talk about those papers,
or more detailed findings
from this one later
or offline with anyone.
So, why did we decide to do this project?
Well, starting about five years ago,
we've seen a series of
high-profile antisemitic incidents
in America.
We've seen the Tree of Life shooting,
the Charlottesville Unite the Right March,
but also more common incidents
like the defacement of synagogues
and harassment of Jewish
Americans, both violently and non.
And all of this has,
perhaps unsurprisingly,
been paralleled by a sharp increase
in perceived concern about antisemitism.
As of last year,
62% of all Americans and
88% of Jewish Americans
now consider antisemitism a problem.
One in four Jews surveyed by the AJC,
or the American Jewish Committee,
said that they had personally
experienced antisemitism
in the past year.
So there's certainly a recent salience
to antisemitism in American politics
and a sense that it's something
worth looking at empirically.
But we also noticed something else
that made this a
compelling topic, which is,
that there's a lot of focus in news media,
and popular commentators,
not just on this rise of antisemitism,
but specifically on how
antisemitism seems to be popping up
on both the far left and the far right.
And I really mean there's a lot of focus,
really quite a lot of focus
about the relationship
between extreme ideology
and antisemitism.
Now this makes sense,
because many of the recent
high-profile antisemitic incidents,
like the ones I just mentioned,
have been associated with either far left
or far right politics,
not just one or the other.
But a prejudice rising on
both ideological extremes,
yet not in the center,
is a fairly unique and interesting pattern
that we don't see very
much in American politics.
So naturally, being the
political scientists that we are,
we decided to focus this project
on getting a clearer
picture of the pattern,
and whether it exists in
mass public attitudes,
instead of just as these anecdotes.
Now we're calling this pattern
the horseshoe pattern of antisemitism,
because it mirrors a
broader theory of ideology
known as horseshoe theory.
And horseshoe theory is the idea
that ideology isn't a straight line
running from far left to far right,
as we would usually think about it,
but instead it's bent like a horseshoe.
So functionally what this means,
is we would have the center
at the top of the horseshoe,
and bent down, so that the
far left and the far right
are actually much closer to each other
than they are to the center.
Now horseshoe theory
became somewhat well
known in American politics
around the 2016 election,
with the simultaneous
rise of the Bernie left
and the Trump right,
which arguably both share a populist base
and frustration with
the prior ruling elites
in both parties.
It hasn't really gained traction
as a broad theory to
explain American politics,
but it has endured in discussions
of American antisemitism,
Two recent popular books,
one by Bari Weiss who used to
work for the New York Times,
and one by Deborah Lipstadt,
a well-known historian
who's now actually leading
the Biden administration's
work on antisemitism,
do a great job of fully
laying out the case
for why this horseshoe
pattern might have arisen.
And why might that be?
Well, extreme antisemitism on both sides
could have a shared cause.
If burgeoning populism
among these extremes
leads to a frustration with
the capitalist status quo,
this could feed into old stereotypes
about Jews as shadowy overlords
who control government and finance,
which could then lead to an increase
in antisemitic attitudes on
both ideological extremes.
But it could also be
for independent reasons
that happen to both be occurring now.
Growing white nationalist
sentiment on the far right
might lead directly to
antisemitic attitudes,
with Jews being seen as a shady group
either pretending to be white,
or siding with the non-white
population politically,
given how liberal American Jews are.
Antisemitic sentiment on the
far left, on the other hand,
may have spilled over from
their views on Israel,
as the political left
has steadily become more supportive
of the Palestinian cause, and
more critical towards Israel.
We've seen progressive politicians
draw direct comparisons
between Black Lives Matter,
a cause that obviously holds
a lot of leftist support,
with the Palestinian cause.
So if the far right has begun
to view Israel negatively,
and as the clear oppressor
in the Palestinian conflict,
those negative views may spill over
towards Jews more broadly.
So we designed this project
primarily to examine whether or not
this horseshoe pattern of antisemitism
exists for either of the above reasons.
But there's one important wrinkle
in the horseshoe pattern of antisemitism
that we really wanted to focus on as well.
And that's what's going
on with young adults,
in terms of antisemitism.
So there's two reasons
why looking at young adults'
antisemitic attitudes here
is interesting.
The first is that we know from prior work
that young adults are
generally more tolerant,
less prejudicial,
hold more cosmopolitan
attitudes than older adults do.
But a number of prior studies have found
that they actually tend to
have higher rates specifically
of antisemitism.
It's been theorized that this may be
to the declining salience of the Holocaust
as we move further away from World War II,
or to the increased salience
of the Israel/Palestine conflict,
particularly given the
more liberal leanings
of young adults.
So we're interested to
see if this is still true.
But we're also interested
to see whether there was
an ideological dimension
specific to young adult antisemitism.
And that's because there are
two ideological movements
that may make the horseshoe
pattern more extreme,
specifically among young adults.
On the right,
we've seen the growth of the
white nationalist alt-right,
which has occurred primarily online,
and thus has gained a large following
specifically among young men.
On the left,
we've seen a huge burst in
pro-Palestinian activism
on college campuses and
in social justice circles,
which are heavily
populated by young adults.
Now both of these movements
may really increase the
pathways to extreme antisemitism
I described on the previous slide,
and thus could accentuate
the horseshoe pattern.
So we focused on young adults
to see if that was indeed the case.
So we wanted to examine mass
attitudes among young adults
and the ideological extremes.
So what did we do?
Of course, we ran an original survey.
It was fielded by YouGov
right after the 2020 election.
And we have this big
2500-person oversample
of younger adults, in order
to really be able to examine
the rise in antisemitism
that might be most prominent
among this age group.
And we also have a 1000-person sample
of the full adult population.
So that gives us a 3500
person sample in total,
which we can and will
break into smaller groups.
Before I get into the meat of the survey,
here's the distribution of
the respondents ideologically.
Most of our analysis
is using a standard
seven-point ideology scale,
going from very liberal
to very conservative.
But we did also duplicate the analysis
using an alternative measure of ideology.
So we explicitly asked respondents
if they identify as more extreme labels,
like alt right, or leftists.
And rerunning all of the
analysis with those labels,
we get essentially the same results.
So for simplicity and
ease of understanding,
I'm gonna present everything here
using this seven-point ideology scale,
but just know that this does hold up,
even if we just look at
more extreme identifiers.
So you can see the distribution here.
We do have more liberal young adults
than we do older adults,
and we also have more liberal young adults
than we do conservative young adults.
But 30% of our young sample
is still conservative,
so that's fairly good,
we have a fairly good distribution here,
and enough to really be able
to analyze these buckets.
Our sample of older adults
is fairly well distributed, as well.
So before I show you the questions we use
to measure antisemitism, I wanna pause,
and note that there have
been decades of debate
about how exactly to define antisemitism,
or what counts as antisemitism,
and it certainly still
remains a hot topic.
So here, we're primarily focusing
on attitudes that respondents
hold towards American Jews.
Do they think of Jews in
stereotypical or demonizing ways,
or do they treat Jews differently
from how they treat other minority groups?
And we decided to measure
this form of antisemitism
in two different ways.
We measure overt antisemitism
via direct agreement with
specific claims about Jews.
And then we also measure
more subtle antisemitism
through a series of experiments
about whether Jews are
held to higher standards
than other groups of Americans.
Now, we do this for two reasons.
The first is to feel more
confident in our results
by triangulating across the
strengths and weaknesses
of these two ways to measure prejudice.
The second reason is to
respond to another key aspect
of the popular discussion
around ideological antisemitism,
which is this repeated idea
that left wing antisemitism
is more subtle,
or that it's more insidious
and gets glossed over,
or that it goes under the radar.
And that this has really allowed the left
to essentially hide its antisemitism,
and avoid addressing it as
sort of real antisemitism.
So in order to try and measure
what these commentators argue
are somewhat hidden views,
we also really wanted to include
these less overt survey experiments,
to potentially draw out these
hidden yet honest views,
if they exist.
So I'm gonna start with our
overt antisemitism battery,
which consists of three questions
with different antisemitic stereotypes.
"Jews are more loyal to
Israel than to America,
"It's appropriate to
boycott Jewish businesses
"as a form of opposition to Israel,"
and that "Jews in the United
States have too much power."
Now these are questions
that have been asked before
by organizations and researchers
to measure antisemitism,
but as an additional check,
we also took any respondent
who said they were Jewish,
and instead of asking them
if they agreed with these statements,
although the results there
might be a little bit interesting,
we instead ask them if they
found them antisemitic.
And across the board,
at least 75% of Jewish respondents agreed
that each statement was antisemitic.
We see agreement as high as
90% for the boycott measure.
So that's another indication
that these are probably
reasonable questions
to gauge antisemitism.
And now we paired this
overt antisemitism battery
with a priming experiment.
Half of our respondents were first primed
with the following quote,
which is a true finding,
explaining that Gallup
found that 95% of Jews
have favorable views of Israel.
And we did this to see
if we could draw out
any of this potentially
masked antisemitism,
since perhaps perhaps priming respondents
who are already critical
of Israel with information
that Jews are an out group
to them on this issue
would make them respond more negatively,
and perhaps more honestly,
about their views of Jews.
Respondents may feel more okay
responding with their true beliefs,
if it could be viewed
as a criticism of Israel
instead of just
antisemitism, in other words.
So we had a few different hypotheses.
First, we expected to find
that antisemitic attitudes
would be higher among
the ideological extremes.
In other words, giving us
this horseshoe-shaped pattern.
We expected to find that younger adults
would in general be more
antisemitic than older adults.
But we also expected that
the horseshoe pattern
would be more extreme
among younger adults.
In other words,
we expected that most of
the increase in antisemitism
among younger adults
would be among the far left
and the far right young adults,
rather than uniformly increased
across all young adults.
And finally,
we expected that the prime about Israel
should increase antisemitic attitudes
specifically on the ideological left,
since that's where we expect
antisemitic attitudes,
if they exist, to be intertwined
with anti-Israel attitudes.
So, what did we find?
Here we have charts showing agreement
with each of the three overt
antisemitism questions.
The X axis on each chart
is going from very liberal
to very conservative,
and we have the percentage
of respondents in each bucket
who agreed with the
statement on the Y axis.
The black dots here show
agreement among younger adults.
Again, those are people aged 18 to 30.
And the gray squares show
agreement among older adults,
or those over 30.
So right off the bat,
we can see that there's no evidence
of horseshoe theory here.
For all three questions among
younger and older adults,
respondents on the far left
have some of the lowest rates of agreement
with the overt antisemitic statements.
So instead of a horseshoe pattern,
which we would expect to
look something like this,
we see that agreement with
antisemitic statements
broadly increases, as we move
from liberal to conservative.
But we can also see
that there's a more complicated
relationship with age here
that seems to be modified by ideology.
There isn't much difference on the left
between younger and older
adults, here, here, and here.
But there's a strong
difference on the right,
and we particularly see
this in the boycott,
and the too much power measure,
and particularly among the
most conservative adults,
there are these huge 40-point gaps here.
So overall, this means that younger adults
do have slightly higher agreement,
especially with the
boycott and power measures,
but that's solely driven
by this really large increase over here
among the young far right,
and it's not at all driven
by any increases among the young far left.
So in all, we don't see
a horseshoe pattern,
and instead we see much higher
agreement on the far right,
particularly on far right.
So moving on to looking at the
prime, which as a reminder,
told respondents first
that 95% of American Jews
have a positive view of Israel.
So this chart shows our
full sample with all adults
just for simplicity
because the results
here don't vary by age.
Here again, we have
ideology on the X axis,
moving from very liberal
to very conservative,
and agreement with each
statement on the Y axis.
So this time, the black dots
represent agreement levels
for respondents who saw the prime.
Whereas the gray squares
represent agreement levels
for respondents who did not.
And we expected that the prime
would increase antisemitic
sentiments on the left,
which probably has more
anti-Israel sentiments as well.
However, we don't really
see that that's the case.
We get null and/or small effects
almost across the board here.
We really do not see much
impact for the prime.
The only place we really
do see substantial effects
is right here, among moderates,
when it comes to agreeing specifically
that Jews are more loyal to
Israel than they are to America.
You see about a 20-point
increase here for moderates.
Now, the prime not working
doesn't necessarily mean
that the left doesn't hold
negative views of Israel.
It could be instead that
it's common knowledge
that Jews hold favorable
views towards Israel
for a lot of our respondents.
And thus they didn't
gain any new information
from the prime.
And perhaps then, the
prime worked on moderates,
specifically for the loyalty measure,
because some research
has found that moderates
may in general know less about politics
and/or be less set in their beliefs.
So they might be more moved by the prime,
specifically for the relevant statement
about Israel loyalty.
Another option could be
that the prime just wasn't strong enough
to counteract social
desirability bias on the left.
So even when prompted with
information about Israel,
they still know
that they shouldn't express
these sentiments about Jews.
Now, this lingering concern
about social desirability bias on the left
brings us nicely to our
double standard experiments,
which we used to see if
respondents across the spectrum
are treating Jews differently
from how they treat other groups.
So these experiments
reduce social desirability concerns a bit,
since we're gonna be
asking the same question,
but with different minority
groups substituted in.
So if they have concerns about
expressing these sentiments,
they should feel it a little less
if it's directly compared
to another group.
So, how do we do this?
Well, again here, we split our
respondents into two groups.
We asked one group if they
thought Jewish Americans
who participate in social justice activism
should have to denounce
Israel's discrimination
against non-Jews.
And we asked the second group
if they thought the same
thing, but for Muslim Americans
denouncing Muslim countries'
discrimination of non-Muslims.
Now we picked this question
because there have been
anecdotal news stories
about organizations,
particularly on college campuses
or in other social justice spaces,
that have pressured Jewish members
to denounce Israel or denounce Zionism
if they want to participate.
And we really wanted a
real world example here,
that respondents might have
thought about or heard about.
- Sorry Laura, just to jump in with
a quick clarifying question.
- Yeah.
- [Josh] Can you explain a little bit more
how this double standard experiment
helps reduce social desirability bias?
You're doing this between subjects design,
so folks are still being asked
either just about Jews
or just about Muslims.
- Yes.
- So why,
if they're being asked about Jews,
don't you think there's a chance
they might hide their true opinion?
- So there definitely is still a chance,
but there's also a chance
they would hide it
against Muslims as well.
So I guess it's sort of
evening the playing field
a little bit about
social desirability bias,
because we can ask
essentially the same question
about two different groups.
So we might think that
social desirability bias
is gonna come into play
for both Jews and Muslims.
- [Josh] Got it, so the assumption is
there's a standard baseline level
of social desirability
bias against both groups,
and we're going to partial that out
by looking at the difference
between the Jews and Muslims.
- Exactly, yeah.
- [Josh] Yeah, seems plausible.
It'd be interesting if you
had data to check that,
but I'll let you keep going.
- Thanks, yeah.
So this chart here now shows results,
with the percentage of respondents,
both from the full sample
and just young adults
who agreed with either statement.
The black squares here
show the respondents
who said that Jews should denounce Israel,
whereas the gray circles show respondents
who said that Muslims should
denounce Muslim countries.
We expected to see
an anti-Jewish double
standard on the left,
and an anti-Muslim double
standard on the right.
So let's just look at the first
half of this chart for now,
the all adults chart.
We see this is the case,
but we see it to different magnitudes.
We see this double standard on the left,
we see this anti-Jewish
double standard on the left,
with the far left
being about 15 to 20 percentage
points more likely to say
that Jews should denounce Israel.
But, looking at the far right,
we see that the far right
is about 40 percentage
points more likely to say
that Muslims should denounce
Muslim discrimination.
And now looking across
the ideological spectrum,
just in this chart, we do see
that those on the far left
are more likely overall
to say that Jews should
have to denounce Israel
than those on the right.
For those on the left,
again, it's around a little less than 50%.
And on the right, it's
down here around 20, 25%.
So this suggests
that there may be some
forms of antisemitism,
such as the one here about holding Jews
to a certain collective standard,
that may be more prominent on
the left than on the right.
But, if we look at just young
adults in the right panel,
we intriguingly see something different.
So here, looking at
respondents' agreements
that Jews should denounce Israel,
we see that both the young far
left and the young far right
are much more likely to
agree with this denouncement
than the center.
So unlike any of our previous findings,
here we do actually see
this U-shaped pattern,
indicating that there is
both a higher standard
for Jews on the left and the right.
And this is our only indication so far
of any pattern that would
match horseshoe theory.
We also see that the results for Muslims
remain relatively similar
as for older adults,
generally increases with
ideology for both cases.
And this suggests that something unique
might be going on here with
young adults and antisemitism.
But, again, there's actually
relatively little change
between all adults on the far left,
and young adults on the far left.
The new U-shaped pattern
is coming from young far right respondents
being about 15 percentage
points more likely
to say that Jews should denounce Israel,
than the older far right respondents were.
So while there is some hint, then,
that the far left is exhibiting
a double standard towards Jews,
that doesn't seem to vary by age.
The young far right, instead,
seems to have become much
more critical of Jews
than older far right adults,
which both lines up with
and provides some nuance
to our prior findings of antisemitism
being the strongest among
the young far right.
So we did a second double
standard experiment as well,
to make sure that our answers
weren't solely being driven
by views on Muslim Americans.
So here, we used Catholic
Americans and Indian Americans
as a comparison group.
Catholics, another
religious group that have
an explicitly religious
country affiliated with them,
in the Vatican, and
they've also been accused
of holding dual loyalty to the Vatican.
We use Indian Americans here
as another group associated
with a foreign ally, India.
And Indian Americans also hold
relatively high socioeconomic
status in the US
for a minority group.
So this double standard experiment
actually had a few questions,
but I'm just gonna show one.
And again, the results are similar
across the different questions.
So we again randomized our
sample into three groups,
and we asked each one
if they thought either Jewish,
Indian, or Catholic Americans
should be held responsible
for Israel, India or
the Vatican's actions.
And here we hypothesized
that both the political
left and the political right
would be more willing
to hold Jewish Americans
responsible for Israel's actions.
This might be the case
due to stereotypes of Jews
as being more powerful
than other minority groups,
but we thought this also might
be present on the far left
due to discourse, again,
around Palestinian activism,
the role Jewish Americans should play,
and general criticism of Israel.
- But looking at--
- Real quick, Laura.
- Yes?
- We just have
a clarifying question from Michelle--
- Yeah.
- Can you talk a little bit
about the X axis of the
liberal, mod, conservative?
So in particular, Michelle wanted to know,
did these subjects identify themselves
as far right or far left?
- Yeah, so here again,
these axes are going from,
we ask people, do you identify
as very liberal, liberal,
somewhat liberal, moderate,
somewhat conservative,
conservative, and very conservative.
So we have very liberal here
and very conservative here.
Again, we did rerun all of this analysis
with specifically more extreme labels,
using leftist, socialist, progressive,
alt-right, Christian
conservative, things like that.
And the results are essentially the same.
But I'm using ideology here
because it's easier to see
a nice trend across ideology
from a more continuous measure.
- [Josh] And we also have
a question from Cheryl
on this measure of,
isn't held accountable very
different from should condemn?
So you could talk about maybe
some of the different measures
you looked at.
- Yeah, definitely, so held accountable,
we wanted to use these
different measures here,
because we didn't want to just
have one specific measure.
So our held accountable measure
is slightly different from
our should condemn measure.
We have another measure,
which is whether or not these groups,
whether Jewish, Indian,
and Catholic Americans
should do more to make
Israel, India, and the Vatican
sort of better countries
or, yeah, better actors, essentially.
And yeah, you're right that these are
potentially picking up
on different things.
So we wanted to change them a little bit
just to make sure, again,
that the specific wording
in any of our measures
wasn't accidentally picking up on a trend
and giving us spurious results.
So, looking at our results here,
we can see once again
that we don't have this horseshoe pattern.
Among all adults on the left,
and among younger adults on the right,
there's no horseshoe pattern,
we don't see any of this U-shaped.
In both cases, adults on the far left
are the least likely to
hold Jews accountable.
And there doesn't even seem to really be
an anti-Jewish double standard here.
We actually find an
anti-Catholic double standard,
which is interesting, but
not the focus of this talk.
The far right also doesn't have
an anti-Jewish double standard.
In both cases, they're the least likely
to say that Jews should
be held accountable.
But, they're still more likely overall
to say that Jews should be
held accountable for Israel
than people on the far left.
And comparing all adults
to younger adults,
we again see that this age effect scales
as we move ideologically
from liberal to conservative.
So there's essentially no change
between younger and
older adults on the left.
But on the far right, we see
that younger far right adults
are about 20 percentage points more likely
to hold Jews responsible for Israel.
Which, again, suggests
that something unique
is going on here with young far
right adults' views on Jews.
So, tying this all together,
what did we learn here
about the ideological
and age patterns of antisemitism?
Well, we first learned that
there isn't much evidence
for a broad horseshoe
pattern of antisemitism.
Even when we do see a U-shaped graph,
antisemitism generally remains
much higher on the right.
And so, we find that
antisemitic attitudes generally
are much higher on the far right
than they are on the far left.
Looking by age.
We do see that young adults
express more antisemitic
attitudes than older ones do.
But this is almost entirely
driven by a large increase
on the young right.
Now we do find a few
anti-Jewish double standards on the left,
including a few more
subtle ones in the paper
that I didn't include here,
because they're along the same lines
as the Jewish-Muslim double standard.
But, in each case,
they're overshadowed by much
stronger anti-Jewish views,
especially on the young
right, for the same questions.
So, I'd say the one-sentence takeaway
from this talk and this paper
is that horseshoe theory
does not seem to accurately
describe antisemitism in America
since we find that the epicenter
is fairly clearly among
the young far right.
But before I end,
I do wanna quickly talk
about our two papers,
which shed light on interesting aspects
outside of horseshoe theory here.
So our second paper in this project
looks at antisemitic attitudes
among racial minorities,
specifically Black and Hispanic Americans.
The prior work has long shown
that these groups do tend to
hold more antisemitic attitudes
than white Americans,
and we find that this is true as well,
particularly among young adults.
Somewhat concerningly,
we find that Black and
Hispanic respondents
agree with these overt
antisemitic statements
at around the same rate
as white alt right respondents do.
So, with this finding,
we then examine whether or not our results
match any previously proposed theories
for minority antisemitism.
These range from greater
Palestinian solidarity,
to minority groups perhaps
conflating Jews with white people
and actually expressing anti-whiteness,
to geographic conflict or
general group competition,
among many others.
So using other questions from our surveys
to test these theories,
we find that actually none
of these common theories
explain the differences that
we find among our respondents.
And this suggests
that we really need a
new wave of theorizing
and a lot more research
into the intersection between
race and antisemitism,
to better figure out what's going on here.
Our third paper is a little different,
and it looks at the young
left's views on Israel.
So underlying a lot of the commentary
on left wing antisemitism,
is the idea that the far left,
particularly the young far
left, really dislikes Israel.
But the extent to which
that's actually empirically
true was unclear.
So, we decided to find out.
So using a few more experiments,
and asking about specific countries,
we find that the young
left does seem to have
this persistently negative
view towards Israel.
They view Israel more negatively
than older liberals do,
or other young adults do.
And young far left adults also
view Israel more negatively
than they view other countries
allied with the United States.
So checking two plausible explanations,
we find that this view
doesn't seem to be explained
by an issue prioritization
of the Israel-Palestine
conflict among the left.
And we also find that
their negative attitudes
extend beyond criticisms
of Israel's government,
and seem to spill over
into criticism of things
like Israel's culture,
languages and religion.
So these findings
also don't fit neatly
with existing theories,
or what we'd expect
from partisan polarized
views of foreign countries.
So, we again argue that more
research is really needed here,
to grapple seriously with what's going on,
with views of both Jews and Israel.
And that's all I have here.
I wanted to mention
that I have a few new
projects I'm starting on
that are somewhat related.
One is on the connection
between antisemitism
and conspiracy theories,
and another is on how the
conditional whiteness of Jews
and Jews' relatively high status
affects perceptions of antisemitism.
But I'd love to hear from
everyone here, any thoughts
on what people found the
most compelling about this,
or best directions to go in from here
with this specific avenue of research.
As well, of course, as any questions
or really any comments
about any part of this.
So, thanks.
- Thank you so much Laura.
Super, super interesting work.
So if folks have any questions,
please put those in the Q and
A and I will moderate them.
We already have a few questions there now.
So first question is "How do
we know that these results
"are not due to random
variability in the sample?
"In other words, were
statistical tests used
"to determine if these results
are actually significant."
So can you talk a little bit
about those conference
intervals on your graphs?
- Yeah, definitely.
So all the confidence intervals,
I guess I should share my screen again,
instead of having stopped shared it.
Yeah, so all of the confidence intervals
shown on our graphs here,
these are 95% confidence intervals.
So we use standard confidence intervals
to test that actually,
these are statistically significant gaps,
and based on, we have a
pretty large sample size,
so we can be pretty sure
that these are statistically significant
and we're actually picking
up on real differences,
instead of random variability.
And again, having sort of this large,
fairly spread out sample
across the ideological spectrum
really helps us here.
- Thanks.
Another question from David Caslow.
"What beliefs are connected
with antisemitism?
"Specifically is the belief in zero sum,
"that there is only a fixed amount
"of happiness, success, money,
"and that an increase in
this amount in one group
"decreases this amount in another group?
"Is this idea of zero sum of belief
"connected with the antisemitism
"and something you studied
in either this paper
"or other work you have ongoing?"
- Yeah, so that comes up.
That's definitely a proposed theory,
that comes up specifically
in a lot of the theories
about racial minorities.
Sort of one of the new theories there
is that there's sort of zero
sum either material resources,
or even zero sum sympathy
that society awards
to different minority
groups who have suffered.
And so some of the antisemitic sentiment
we could be picking up on
might be because Jews are perceived
as both sort of the victims
of antisemitism, but, again,
they're well off in
America socioeconomically.
So this does create sort
of this odd tension of,
"Well, they're being
discriminated against,
"but they're doing better
than other minority groups."
So that's something I'm really
interested in looking at
with my next project about
views of privilege and status
and how that affects
perceptions of antisemitism,
does that lead people to be
less sympathetic towards Jews
or to express more antisemitic
sentiments in general?
- Question from Eran Rubenstein.
So have you looked at any sort
of geographical differences,
specifically urban
versus non-urban pattern
in these results?
And I'll add on top of that
is, have you looked at,
especially among the young people,
college educated versus
not college educated?
- Yep, so we look at both of these things.
So I didn't include any of
our regression tables here,
because I think it's
generally very overwhelming
when someone puts up a gigantic
regression table in a slide.
But all of these results here
that I'm showing on graphs,
we do regression analysis as well,
and we find the same
results for all of them.
But in those cases,
we're able to control
for college education,
and geography in particular.
So we look at both of those things.
And specifically in our paper
about racial minority antisemitism,
those are two common confounder
theories that are proposed,
for why racial groups
might have higher rates of antisemitism.
And we basically dismiss both of those.
So yes, we have information about college,
which we've used to confirm.
For geography, we only
have state-level data
unfortunately, from YouGov.
So we can't do anything as direct
as Ryan Enos does in his work,
when he can directly sort of look at
how neighborhoods and
contact increases prejudice.
But, there are actually a lot of states
where there are essentially no Jews.
So we do compare people who
respond from those states,
assuming they have essentially
no contact with Jews,
with people responding from states
that have a much higher Jewish population,
like New York, California, Florida,
and we don't see...
All of these things still persist,
all of our results still
persist and are robust to that.
- In a related question
from Michelle Edgar, so,
"Some states require holocaust education
"as as part of the K through 12 schooling
"and other states do not.
"Have you looked at whether
there are any differences
"between states that have
"that Holocaust education requirement
"and states that don't?"
- Yeah, we haven't looked at that,
but that's actually a great idea,
and something that I'm curious
about and might fit into
maybe the project about
perceptions of Jews,
is along those lines, but it's about,
when we ask people questions about Jews,
presumably a large
portion of our respondents
don't know any Jewish people.
So what are they thinking about?
There's probably some
respondents who are like,
"Oh, my friends are Jewish,
"and they're completely normal people.
"I like them."
But if you don't know Jews,
what are you thinking of
when you think of a Jewish American?
Are you thinking of some
stereotype of a Hasidic Jew
living an insular community?
Because that's often how,
especially observant Jews,
are portrayed in media and in the news.
Or are you thinking of a random Reform Jew
who lives in your town and
lives in your community?
So that's something that I
think is really interesting
and I would love to look at more,
because I'm very interested in how
what people know about Judaism
and how all these things
lead to different views on Jews
and different parts of antisemitism.
- And I guess following up
on that question about stereotypes, so,
I think Susan Fiske has done some work
on stereotypes towards Jews,
and if I remember correctly,
she finds that most Americans
hold these stereotypes
where Jews are viewed
as as high competence
but maybe low on warmth or viewed coolly.
Assuming that my recollection is correct,
does she look at all across
either age or ideology,
and does she see any sort of difference
along the patterns that
you're finding here,
or have you looked at--
- Yeah.
- These types of like Susan
Fiske stereotypes questions
in your own work?
- Yeah, I'm not sure off the
top of my head what she finds,
but that's something
that I have been thinking
about a lot here.
I know there's also work on
how Asian Americans are viewed,
and sort of the idea of
racial triangulation,
which has been going back, I don't know,
a decade, two decades.
And the idea that minority groups
aren't just viewed on a certain
spectrum, as we would say,
from bad to good.
But there's a sense of, yeah,
are they viewed coolly or
warmly, or in another sense,
are they viewed as Americans
or are they viewed as permanent outsiders?
And then also are they viewed
as competent to incompetent, essentially?
And so I think there
definitely is this push,
within a lot of the prejudice literature,
to think of things not
just on a single spectrum,
and that's something I would definitely
want to expand this work out to,
'cause I think it's an
obvious place to go from here.
- So we have a few questions from folks
on what I'll call the why question.
Why is it that the young left
uniquely dislikes Israel?
Have you thought about this,
have you started to investigate it,
what is the role of of social
media, or media more broadly,
and opinion leadership,
and a different crop of elected officials
coming from the left, and
their views towards Israel?
Just, yeah, what have you thought about
when it comes to this question of why,
have you started to answer
this question, if not,
how do you think you would
go about answering this?
- Yeah, great question.
I have definitely thought
a lot about why this is.
The question of media, I think.
Okay, so, we can say
one potential reason is,
that the far left is
actually just antisemitic,
and they're channeling all of those views
into a more socially
acceptable sort of output,
which would be criticism of Israel.
That is sort of one extreme,
that may or may not be the case.
But there's lots of other potential ideas
that we need to check first.
The biggest one is probably this question
of media and exposure.
So it might be that people on the far left
really just see lots
more news about Israel,
they see a lot more news
about Israel and Palestine.
Either because news media covers it more
than conflicts in other
countries, which is probably true.
Or that people on social media,
these opinion leaders, as you talk about,
are posting more about
Israel and Palestine.
We see, especially, the
squad, you know, AOC,
Rashida Tlaib, Ilhan
Omar, Ayanna Pressley,
they talk about Israel
and Palestine quite a bit.
So it could be that the far left
holds these uniquely
negative views on Israel,
just because they know
more and they are exposed
to more negative criticism of Israel,
and also just exposed in general
to what's going on there.
Because there's so much
going on in the world,
and we know people can't
really hold real opinions
about what's going on in
every single country at once.
So, I would say those are
sort of the two extremes
as to what could be going
on with the far left.
And it could be anywhere
along that spectrum.
I haven't yet started
digging into why that is,
in part because it's a thorny issue,
it's hard to really get at the core
of why do people feel
this way about Israel?
Because again, with social
desirability bias coming in,
if you ask someone who
really is antisemitic,
who holds negative views of Israel,
why do you feel this way?
They're probably gonna come up
with a reasonable justification
that's not "I hate Jews."
So, it's a tricky thing
to get at, but I think,
actually going back to what
we were just talking about,
exploring what people
actually know about Israel,
and what they know about the
conflict, and things like this,
could be one way to go about it.
And I've considered something...
I talked earlier about
a lot of the parallels
that are drawn between Black Lives Matter
and the Israel-Palestine conflict.
And something I'm broadly
interested in is whether,
especially people on the far left,
not only see those as parallels,
but sort of impute US race relations
onto Israel and Palestine.
So do they view Israelis, as
they view Jews in America,
who are primarily white?
And do they view Palestinians as,
they're primarily Arabs, so,
"Okay, Muslims in the United
States are viewed as not white,
"so I will view them as not white."
And that's sort of a simple issue
for the far left to have a stance on.
Because here in the United States,
white people they would
view as the oppressors, so,
they can do the same as
Israel and Palestine.
Now, we also know that,
I believe still the
majority of Jews in Israel
are not Ashkenazi, they're not white,
they're not coming from
Europe or even America.
So I'm interested, one
thing I had a thought about,
is if you prime people with information
about racial demographics in Israel,
about Israelis and Palestinians,
does that change any
views they have on Israel?
And I haven't really thought
it through further than that,
but that's something
I would be really interested to work on,
and someone should do, if not me.
- You should do it,
it's a great next step.
And a few questions sort
of from the the other side,
the far right.
So, one question is about
just why you think this is,
there's an age gap on the far right,
between younger and older?
And a related question
is about religiosity.
How much of this do you think is driven
by religiously-based antisemitic attitudes
that might hold both among
right-wing white Christians,
but also among the Black
and Latino population
that is more religious?
- Yeah, so,
religiosity is an easier answer, which is,
we actually control for this,
both in the ideology paper
and specifically in the
minority antisemitism paper.
And we do find often higher
rates of antisemitism
among more religious people.
But, these patterns do persist,
even just looking at
more religious people,
still people on the far right
agree more with these
antisemitic statements,
and the same for breaking
down racial minority groups.
So, religiosity certainly
plays a role in people's views
on Jews and antisemitism,
but it doesn't explain any of
these patterns specifically.
Going back to why I think young far right
might be more likely to agree.
There's a few things.
One is, well, maybe it's
sort of the same thing.
I talked about the growth of
the alt-right movement online.
Part of sort of the ethos
of the alt-right movement
and people on the young
far right in general,
is this sort of reactionary attitude
to a lot of so-called
political correctness,
things like that that are going on.
And we see people on the young far right
being more willing to just
express hateful views broadly,
we can think about how
social media trolling
might have played a role in that.
So it might be that people
on the young far right,
it could be that there's actually
a decreased social desirability bias
among young far right adults,
it could be that there're
being reactionary,
they think it's good to
share these honest attitudes,
they're like, "I'm not afraid to say
"what I actually think about Jews,"
and perhaps other minority groups.
But it also could be that because
lots of these white
nationalist, alt-right movements
are growing online,
they're particularly
attracting young adults,
who are overwhelmingly more online,
who are gonna find these communities,
they're gonna be on
4chan, things like that.
And it could be that just
this increased exposure,
to all of this, is making them express
more antisemitic attitudes in general.
- And one question from David Nelson is,
is there a way to separate
out these attitudes from,
let's call it genuine attitudes
versus peer-based attitudes,
where in some groups it's the cool thing
or the in-group thing
to hold these antisemitic attitudes,
even if the individual expressing them
does not truly harbor these
antisemitic attitudes.
- Yeah.
- Do you have any thoughts on that,
and I guess a related question would be,
is there a relationship
between these attitudes
and any type of antisemitic behavior?
- Yeah, both of those are great questions.
We don't have any way of linking that
to antisemitic behavior,
and I'm not sure if anyone has
ever asked those questions,
but that would be
a really interesting
thing to look at as well.
I think it's a great question,
and I think partially what it's getting at
is this idea of expressive
responding on surveys.
Which is sort of a problem, a concern
that comes up more broadly
in political science.
Which is, what if people,
when they take a survey,
what if they're not responding
with their genuine view,
but they're responding with the view
they know they should hold
based on some identity?
And we're often really
concerned about this
when it comes to partisanship,
and thinking about polarization.
So we see very polarized views
among the left and the right
on all sorts of policy issues.
And one question is, well,
if you ask people their views
on affirmative action, for example,
are people who are saying,
"Well I'm a Democrat, so I'm
supposed to support this,
"so I'll say yes."
Are they saying that when
they fill out a survey
or are they actually truly in
support of affirmative action?
It's very hard to
disentangle these things,
and that could be part
of what's going on here.
I would say, it's partially, I would lean,
my gut instinct is that
that's less of a concern
with our question specifically
than with a lot of these
more policy-based questions,
because it's not exactly clear
that there should be a strict party divide
on these issues.
You know, we might think,
"Oh, white nationalists, they're
gonna dislike Jews less."
But the Republican Party is
also very supportive of Israel.
And of course,
that doesn't mean that
they're not antisemitic,
these two views are sort of separate, but,
a lot of people on the far
right would probably say,
"Oh yeah, I am supportive of Jews,
"I support Israel, I
support all these things."
So it's not clear exactly
that there would be such
strong expressive responding.
But it is something worth exploring
and looking at more, definitely.
- Perhaps one way you could get at this
is about people's
perceptions of group norms,
so you could ask them, what
percent of your friends
do you think would agree
with this statement
about double standards?
And to see if there's a gap
between those group norm
perceptions and people's positions.
- Yeah, that's a great idea, thanks.
- So we are almost at the top of the hour.
I believe this talk has been recorded
and will be shared, Inasela, somewhere,
if you wanna chime in, I meant--
- Yeah, sure.
- Since if we got
a question on that.
- [Inasela] Yes, it will be
posted on the YPSA website.
It's ypsa.yale.edu.
In a couple of weeks.
- Great, thanks.
And Laura, if folks are interested
in reading these additional papers,
is there a place where they
can go to access those?
- Probably.
(chuckles)
I would guess they're probably
on my co-author Eitan Hirsch's website,
so you could go there, but also,
anyone is free to contact
me, reach out on Twitter.
You can find my email and email me,
and I'd be happy to share this more
with anyone who's interested.
- So folks are interested
in the other papers that
we got a brief intro to,
but lots of discussion about,
please reach out to Laura on those.
So yeah, thank you all so much,
and I hope everyone has
a great Friday afternoon
and a lovely weekend.
- Thanks everyone!